it has been a little more than six  months since the attack on the u.s  capitol and now political battling has  intensified over the committee that's  trying to get formed to investigate what  happened  yesterday house speaker nancy pelosi  rejected two republican picks for that  committee  both outspoken supporters of former  president donald trump  gop house leader kevin mccarthy calls  the decision by miss pelosi in abusive  power  pelosi says the move was necessary  speaker pelosi has taken the  unprecedented step of denying the  minority party's  picks for the select committee on  january 6th  this represents something that has not  happened in the house before for a  select committee by the historian  the committee is scheduled to hold its  first meeting on this next  week